IDO GREEN: Hi, I'm
Ido Green, a developer
advocate for Actions on Google.
In my last video--
link up here--
I showed you how to create
a trivia template to create
an app without any code.
Now I'll show you how to
use the personality quiz
template to create a new app
for the Google Assistant.
The best part of
this template is
that you don't need any code.
We've made it easy to
you to get started.
In addition to showing
you how to build
an app with a template,
I'll share some suggestions
on how to create traits
and outcomes for the quiz
and how to submit
your app for review.
Let's check it out.
To get started, open
the Action console.
There are three template
options you can choose from.
To select the
personality quiz, simply
click on the Build button.
The next few steps are the same
for all three app templates.
Click the Next under
the bips, the robot,
to select this personality.
Now we're getting the part where
you get to customize your app.
Click on Upload Content
Via Google Sheet.
Click on the hyperlink to
create a copy of the template
we've made for you.
You'll get a new browser
tab with this option.
Click on the Make a Copy button.
Make sure to change the
content on all three tabs
we provided here.
The blue sections
should not be changed.
We suggest to design
the personality quiz
by first defining your
outcomes and traits,
then working backwards
to your questions.
For example, the traits speed,
supernatural, flight, stealth,
alien, and strength could
be useful for a superhero
personality quiz.
The personality quiz
uses traits to map a user
to a possible outcome.
It will ask one
question for each trait,
and their response
will mark that trait
as either positive or negative.
When the quiz is over, the
final values of all the traits
build a profile that is
mapped to the closest
matching outcome.
Keep in mind best
practices like answers
work best when they require
three or fewer words.
Keep questions clear
and short, and keep
the answers even shorter.
Check out the
description for a link
to even more best practices.
Once the questions and
traits are filled in,
and positive and
negative are identified,
click on the Outcome tabs
and fill this in as well.
This will help the algorithm
match the right final results
based on the user's answers.
Lastly, click on the
Configuration tab
and make sure to change
the values of each cell
to fit to your app.
After that, you're done here.
Copy the Google Sheet
URL and paste it
into the previous screen in the
Google Sheet browser URL field.
Click on Connect.
Once your content is
uploaded successfully,
click on Create App, which
will close this wizard.
Congrats!
You've just finished
the hard part.
And it wasn't hard
at all, right?
Now it's time to take
your app for a test drive.
Click on the simulator
on the left side,
or on the Test App button.
Here is what the
simulators look like.
We'll focus on the left side.
The web simulator is a great
tool for testing your app
and seeing how it's going to
work on the Google Assistant.
It's important to test that
everything is working well
before submitting
your app for a review.
As you can see, you
could talk or type
to test your personality quiz.
By the way, if you are
logged into your Assistant
with the same account on
your phone or Google Home,
you could test your
creation there as well.
Once you've tested your
app, you're done building,
and it's time to move
on to the app review.
Make sure your app follows our
content guidelines and best
practices--
link below-- before submitting
it to Google for review.
If your app is approved, it will
be available to all Assistant
users.
To submit your app for review,
go to the Overview page
for your project in
the Actions console.
Click on the App
Information section.
Click Add, and fill out
the requested information.
Most of this
information is public
and appears in the
system directory.
When you are done filling
out your app information,
you'll return to the
Assistant App Draft page.
You can skip the location
targeting section, the surface
capability section, and
account linking section
by clicking Next.
Remember, template apps work
on all surfaces supported
by the Google Assistant.
Click Submit Draft for
Review to submit your app.
To learn even more about
the review process,
check out the link in
the description below.
That's it.
You're all done.
Thanks for watching.
Check out the
YouTube description
below for more links
to our documentation,
and be sure to check
out my other video
on how to publish an app
for the Google Assistant
that will pass the review.
Until next time, be strong,
and create amazing Actions.